one by one after taking down his
officers the main and final target
captain lewis has made himself known but
there is something off about this one
something doesn't feel quite right
regardless based on what his lieutenants
have been up to he needs to be taken
down
[Music]
[Music]
frederick lewis spent many a summer on
the ocean rescuing inexperienced
tourists who'd got themselves into
trouble of the north carolina
coastline's unforgiving seas
with the help of his father's small
fishing boat and the fact that he had
spent the majority of his life on the
ocean lewis was the perfect man for the
job
he had always seen himself as a savior
and the best person to bring back those
missing at sea to their loved ones
so unsurprisingly at the completion of
high school he joined the coast guard
and over the course of time worked his
way up into the prestigious search and
rescue team
eventually lewis married and at the
request of his new wife they moved to a
homestead in kentucky
with the property value of the old
fishing shack ballooning they were able
to buy a large estate which consisted of
40 acres
yet soon after lewis grew tired of
playing the part of a farmer and decided
to join the national guard in the hopes
of once again finding his true purpose
though after all of his sacrifices for
his wife's happiness and moving away
from the sea he loved so much in
attempting to live a less thrilling life
for the betterment of their relationship
she was the one who started looking
elsewhere
the young man they hired to help around
the farm was the perfect candidate and
two years after their big move to
kentucky she had an affair
when lewis discovered the relationship
he was devastated
after everything he'd given up he still
wasn't enough for her
so he quietly packed up his bags
collected his faithful dog got into his
truck
and left
lewis knew there was only one place he
truly felt whole
the ocean
his father in the sea welcomed him back
with love and open arms
once there he rejoined the coast guard
and tried to rebuild his shattered soul
yet his efforts would soon be undermined
again
as not long after his return to north
carolina the green poison was released
sent to dc to help support the jtf the
impact of his experiences including his
failed marriage led him to be cold nasty
and unmerciful to those he was entrusted
to lead and protect
captain lewis
we ready for homecoming just a few
things to take care of here and i'll be
on my way
advanced team is already on location
lieutenant chang's delivered and we have
more than enough supplies for the party
that's great news
when major castillo got to dc he
recorded some very emotional reports
we decided to make some of them public
no greater recruiting tool than a
civilian who found purpose with the true
sons careful captain you keep delivering
work this good
i might think you're after my job
not to worry general i hate the office
politics working with the team that's
where i belong
making sure the trains run smoothly and
we all come back safe
that's where i know i can be of service
leadership support roles and
infrastructure that's the work that
fuels me
we need people like you captain that's
the thing about the division a bunch of
lone wolves with no real infrastructure
and alliances they were set up to fail
hire a bunch of specialists train them
to use another to solve their problems
this is what you get
you can't depend on someone and build
trust if you only talk to them when you
need something people like that aren't
willing to acknowledge their
shortcomings or ask for help until
they're already in trouble this is why i
knew following you and ridgway was the
right call he was proactive
he was willing to make the tough calls
because he saw where the road was
heading
and now that he's gone we will finish
the journey together and bring our cause
to every state in the nation
good luck in dc
captain lewis checks in with general
anderson to give him an update on how
his team has been going in dc
everything is running according to plan
and he's ready to enact his part of the
operation
but one thing is for certain neither of
them hold the division in particularly
high regards
referring to them as a failed initiative
flawed from its inception
status report
we are getting ready to take the network
but there have been some unexpected
roadblocks
increased instability in the power grid
surges and blackouts some data anomalies
insecure calms and increased brute force
attacks
some of my men are reporting that they
have seen some odd lights and feel like
they are being watched
i thought the stress is getting to them
but the reports are coming from all
times a day and from folks i trust
major zander is looking into it but i
don't know that our methods will yield
the results we're looking for
once in dc unusual reports start
flooding in
xander was set forth in order to find
out what's going on but lewis doesn't
expect her direct approach will provide
the results they need
however this doesn't matter for now the
target they've been hunting for has been
found
captain lewis and his men set course and
head there immediately
lewis what's your eta
should be arriving at the party by
sundown tomorrow negative i need you
there now we've got a location there's
movement
looks like they are getting ready for an
extraction we need to head them off the
pass
permission to take main roads and make a
loud entrance permission granted
this will put us on the division's radar
it was inevitable maybe this time
they'll actually see what we've been up
against i hope you're right
frankly if they haven't figured out
what's going on by now i don't think
they ever will
lone wolves they have no trust and no
support network you pull one pin and the
entire communication chain breaks down
this is why we have contingencies
send me the coordinates i'll get my team
there asap
the division caught up with captain
lewis at the jefferson trade center
but before the agents could enter lewis
puts out a message over the comms
this is captain lewis black tusk taking
jefferson train center we need backup
lewis this is kelso put down your
weapons and surrender the division will
take care of the black tusk it's not the
black tusk you should be worried about
have your team meet me inside
i don't trust this guy
don't shoot him
i want to know what he's up to
lewis is the last member left of his
team and he warns that it isn't the
black task that are the problem that
there is something worse within these
walls
someone he refers to as the recruiter
finally
what's your status
armed and ready but the lone survivor of
my team if you want us to help you we
need you to secure the shade node you
don't trust me to have your back i don't
trust you to have my front
that trust has to be earned
captain defend the node we can take care
of black tusk watch out for the
recruiter the what oh you'll see
trust has to be earned
well kelso doesn't trust him for now the
agents and lewis will be teaming up
against this new threat
unknown
what the [ __ ] i lost you for a second i
thought maybe the captain took out the
nodes
leading this operation
and that this is some sort of test for
him
you ready
yes tell bonnie to stop checking up on
me i know what i'm doing
you know this is a test right it's his
test not mine i'm not looking for a
promotion
that's why i'm checking up on me
oh the agents catch up with lewis
outside of the shd node where he has
secured the area stopping the black tusk
from once again taking down the shd
network
agent kelso the true sons have secured
the entrance to the shade node your
columns are secure
thank you captain
no problem agent
true sons know how to follow orders
sir get ready to be impressed
agent i've got you covered captain what
are you doing the rest of the facility
is secure i'm providing air support we
can't let bonnie get away what do you
mean air support hey agent unless you
need a powder shower might work
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
agent i don't want you breathing that
[ __ ]
friendly fire my ass
rogue striker
you're not the only one with air support
after fighting through the hordes of
black tusk troops the agents would
eventually meet up with bonnie in the
final courtyard
although he had brought along a
marauder-class quadcopter the agents
would slowly take it down
and with the unwanted help of captain
lewis's dc 62 airstrikes bonnie 2 would
be eliminated
[Music]
identification confirm agent jack body
status classified
deceased
he was an agent
classified
bring me his watch
i've never seen that status before
what the [ __ ] is going on here captain
you know nothing kelso
so
not friends if you finally figured out
what the hell we're really up against
you know where to find me
knock it off with the yellow powder or
next time i'll have to kill you myself
talk to your boy you're gonna need our
help my boy who the [ __ ] is my boy
so there is a lot to unwrap with this
one firstly lewis helping us
was general anderson aware of this
based on the last conversation we had
with them at the end of the mission they
seem to know a lot more about what's
going on than we do
which
seems to be a recurring theme to be fair
they certainly knew about the recruiter
which appears to be what they've been
hunting down through this whole
operation
speaking of hunting this recruiter was a
hunter
given that bonnie was being tested and
this recruiter was just hanging around
all mission watching it could be pretty
safe to say that bonnie was attempting
to join the hunters sort of like a
hunter intern
and now that we know that the hunters
are a part of homeland security this
explains the watch and the gadgets that
bonnie was using
we now know why those emp drones were
hovering around all the way through this
manhunt we were being watched or maybe
the targets were but why i'm not really
sure
there is a lot more to talk about here
including that final cut scene with
kelso and manny but i'm going to leave
that to the next video where we'll go
through the new fellow comms that came
through at the end of this manhunt i'm
working on these as we speak so
hopefully not too far off
thanks for watching and i'll catch in
the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay